i've been playing soccer on a hot summer
day
i love a frozen fruit pop right after i
play who doesn't but even though i want
one i just stand at the sink cause i'm
so hot and tired that i can't even think
in case i can't remember how to cool
myself down i wrote the steps on paper i
can pass them around
read me the instructions and i'll follow
along and i'll have my refreshment by
the end of the song we get where you're
going we'll
one page at a time
open up the freezer door
get out the pop that you're looking for
have a taste and shout hooray
[Music]
that wasn't as refreshing as i would
have thought but we can solve a problem
with the steps that we've got the secret
is the sequence the order they're in so
rearrange the sequence and we'll sing it
again
we need a new sequence so mix up the
line and read the instructions one page
at a time
open up the freezer door
get out the pop that you're looking for
take off the wrapper and throw it away
have a taste and shout hooray
[Applause]
[Music]
hooray
[Music]
hooray
[Music]